butter beer all around
we are back with another round of photo
battle royale this one is even crazier
than the other one it goes i actually i
can't spoil it you'll just have to watch
it if you want to see the other one
there's a link in the description below
or probably here as a tag or something
like that but the rules are simple if a
photo of you gets posted to the group
thread you are eliminated we split up
the teams of two it's last man standing
all right second stick three
all right calling it in two minutes 155
split up what are we what are we doing
i'm watching them watch them from afar
like eagles
let's stick to our original game plan
dude dude if we go this way i'm going to
get distracted sam think about the game
you want to lose do you want to be a
loser oh [ __ ] is there like a green
screen we can stand on
get your phone ready
any time it shoots
go tackle shoot
there they're gonna be right there
so we just gotta wait a moment
strategy for this one i don't know i
can't go back to cannon mountain but
that'd be foolish
oh my god ren's right there
oh no they were right there how did i
not see them let me get out of here dude
no the game's not started yet i did not
get any photos for the record they're
stalking us they're literally following
us right now
sam sam don't go this way sam sam don't
go this way i want to i want to switch
dude no there they are right there there
they are right there
is the game on not yet one minute
dude go right around this corner we got
to jump on them right now we know where
they are they also know where we are so
let's uh let's go that way no let's go
this way it just started oh [ __ ]
dude watch out they're coming right
through here
i see you i see
there's friends
um they're not there anymore so let's
just go that way got him already out of
the game let's get out of the third go
ahead wait did we just get got
we got got we might run into him up here
yeah we gotta confirm
dude the thrill did you see nick and
nico run that way did you they're on
this side
sam must be over here he must be close
where is he there's christian
sam's around here this is dangerous this
is a dangerous place to be these long
hallways we got sniped like this earlier
dude yeah where's where's christian
i think you just swing out to the
preview
scary business
if you were nick and nico where would
you go yo
hey what's up
there they are down here
so we're safe right now we can be in the
open because we've already been god we
just got to find christian christians
save us no actually this is what we got
to do we got to wait we got to wait till
another team drops out then we revive
and we're good to go
if another team drops
that means a win there's winner oh snap
you're right that's game yeah where's
christian though you got to find him
there's christian
there's christian right there
christian
christian
better hurry up before i call
go go go go go go go
[ __ ] is it in there do i have it no i
don't have it
wait wait i don't have it i haven't been
able to ride it yet all right i haven't
called it yet and i haven't gotten the
textbook
i just got the text so that means we got
in before he called it revive happened
before i can call it we're still alive
official rules
experience you guys need a revive
what yeah nico double double tap you
guys oh my goodness
hurry get that revive all right let's
get out of here sam
ren
oh they're right there they're right
there
i did i sent it i got see mike i got
t-mic too okay did you get rent because
rin got us dude they probably got a
double kill on us yeah the question is
who got the kill first
i i totally snapped photos before i even
knew we were there
are we dead i don't know so we still
gotta get sam and jake uh christian
called he's like nico and nick need to
revive uh jake and sam are still in yeah
they're still in
what are you doing
uh i'm making something delicious butter
beer but before that you need context
[Music]
hey i grew up liking fantasy stuff
dragons magics that includes wizards
lord the rings even harry potter i
watched the harry potter movies as a kid
i did not read the books does that make
me as an adult i love going to the harry
potter theme park you know the one at
universal one of my favorite things to
do there is go to the three broomsticks
have a good hearty meal and then finish
it off with some butter beer it's a
great sweet drink and i really really
love it problem is in january i became
vegan and the butter beer is not vegan
to solve this problem i went online and
i looked up some recipes and i'm gonna
make vegan butter beer
the recipe i found online start with
sparkling apple cider soy vanilla ice
cream imitation butter non-dairy creamer
ground nutmeg grounded ginger and then
ground cinnamon supposedly this is all i
need there should be a measuring cup
here
snape's gonna fail me right now he's
gonna poison me by the end of this
episode i know it hey siri how many
millimeters are in an ounce
i'm not putting that in the video how
many millimeters wait millimeters
i have the elder one and then i have the
resurrection right yeah you got some
hard trucks up in here if i get the
invisibility cloak i'm technically
immortal i've had the butter beer at
universal i
didn't
really like it so so carmichael you
might get a kick out of this people in
the electric vehicle area are starting
to call internal combustion engines
muggles place all the ingredients except
for the apple juice pinch of ginger do
you want to play the ginger challenge
ground cinnamon
get
some butter in there okay so you're only
doing the one serving as a test then
you're going to make a second serving
for everyone in the studio you're all
going to get the try butter beer who has
the black shirt on we're dead we're dead
we're dead we're dead we're dead
so after a flurry of violence me and
nick wipe the teams but they'll revive
before we could actually seal the deal
so chris got to do it again you ready
nick let's do it man last time
all right everybody's on their last
night this is the last revive oh so
they're back in they're right over there
go down the tunnel
okay no they're really close they're
over here somewhere i just saw them take
care someone took a picture let's get
out of this area and go go flank them
the key to success is moving sam
remember
why are we down on the ground this is
really awkward everyone's taller than us
everybody's gotten better at this game
they're moving way more stealthy i'm
gonna go back to my hiding spot let's go
to let's go to cannon all right everyone
is alive and on their last life this is
anyone's game
seriously this is super intense i'm
getting these adrenaline spikes
we're trying to go to canada trying to
go to canada dude just crossing the open
waiting for that buzz in your hand to
signify your death i feel like sony
might be the end game wait why don't we
go into the sony booth and say hey come
to the sony move if you want to learn
yeah do it do it yeah then we'll sculpt
them from here i told them that you
can't come to sony and come out alive
all right let's hit the wall and screw
up the sunny nose guys
what sony sam just texted saying come to
sony if you're not a wuss i can't let
them call me out like that we gotta go
dude looks yeah the first the first
thing they're going to think is that
we're going to be waiting here at the
entrance so they're going to try to
flank the entrance so we have to go to
the back over there
right here is dude right here we can see
everybody if we just hang back here i'm
ready
there it is
no dude i got you though i know i sent a
text to you and niko
i'm christian's gonna have to be the
judge on the rep on this we got we got
one more team one more man see you later
all right good luck all right bye guys
soy cream soy soy cream now that all the
spices the butter and the ice cream or
in the cup now i add a cider now i'm
mixing up here look up here
there you go
yeah there are chunky
let's grab a blender but before i do
that i want to mention that audible is
sponsoring this video i want to tell you
why i'm doing this in an audible
sponsored video audible has an unmatched
selection of audiobooks shows comedy and
newspapers and more audible's offering
you a free audio book with a 30-day
trial just go to audible.com saminiko or
text sam and eco to 500 500
to start today at all that comes last
same nico so when i was a kid the reason
why i didn't read the harry potter books
is
i'm not a really good reader i would
find it very intimidating to read other
kids in the class they read and hear the
pages flip faster than you can get
through and then the more i didn't read
the less i felt like
it really messed with me as a kid and i
was surprised how much it affected me as
an adult when i first heard about
audible i was very negative towards it i
thought it was stupid one day i actually
just felt like i want to read harry
potter i didn't have the books on me
installed audible at one credit i got
the first harry potter book using the
link this uh audible.com sam anika i got
that one credit i tried out harry potter
it's almost been a month now and i'm
already on the fourth book everything
still works the same as if i was reading
images people places magic it's just
it's all there my brain is active my
creativity has gone up in the last month
i've written over 200 pages of stuff an
app has done that for me over the last
month
and it's really changed my life
sparkling it's carbonated i shouldn't
have done this at all
whoa it's like curdles i don't know if
you're supposed to blend it bro
it's just a cream though
it's not real butter beer
maybe we should just rewind
let's rewind a bit
failure is a part of everything you
can't grow up you can't succeed you
can't learn and you definitely can't win
without losing first
better
third time
mix spices and creamer
what that looks weird add a scoop of ice
cream on top it looks more like beer
number one two three
[Music]
it's time for the guys your christian
i'm gonna cast a spell on your taste
buds
[Music]
so let me explain this was
number one i would like you guys to try
number one
drink
[Music]
hmm
it's definitely like a dessert this the
solids man yeah i can't really taste
much because i'm sick why is it so
chunky it tastes like
some sort of batter
you
would you say that you improved on
version two i i would say i haven't
proved what is in this butterbeer what
does that never have butterbeer looks in
the movie exactly that's why we're gonna
get to number three what is in this can
we just go to number three no why can't
we just go to number three it's an
adventure okay i think this one's better
number three butterbeer all around
oh oh
no
no
um at universal when you go they like
pour the beer and then they put foam on
top of it like it's two separate things
is that what you did that's what i did
for the third one
thank you hey carmichael yeah that's
actually not bad
it's gross
i don't think it was as bad as niko said
it was it's just but as far as the taste
goes and all stuff like it's totally
good i think i'm gonna have to finish
the books on audible to find out how to
make real butter beer i'll lead
uh
so everything's going down at the sony
booth we gotta get there dude i told you
we should have just gone that way
they're already on their way i guarantee
yeah yeah they're already on their way
all right we have to be careful that's
how they got shot in the back equip your
two-time scope equipped
christian has eliminated sam and jake
they are out it is just nick and nico
left
okay so here's the plan stay here i'm
gonna go across the opening and they'll
find me you get them as they come out
okay you just stay here and zoom in
there he is
go
go
i can't get the shot
too many foreground elements
[Music]
yeah i'm going to edit the photo and
send it nice work good tonight
i had to do a post on that
where there's smoke there's fire ren's
gotta be here somewhere
carmichael why'd you
you left me again i might just go for it
we're going to try to find ren who's the
last player in the game he's somewhere
here
beautiful
[Music]
how far away is your journalist your
journalist is nowhere near you it
doesn't count he's fired and you're
fired
where's nick
how far away is nick
nico
you guys got fired over here no no where
is he stay right here where is he
where is he right there
right there where i don't see him no no
nico
no nico you're cheating
oh
i was hiding behind that chair in the
corner and you walked right by i was
standing there that whole time did you
know that dude you're the coach's
champion again
[Music]
i find
did it nick
survived you survived it was so close
it was so close if sam was the judge's
phone you would have died first it's
first on my phone because that's why we
have to use mine as the media oh hey you
said it
oh yeah he's the master
there's a little bit of controversy over
our victory apparently nick and i
splitting up and not being able to claim
where each other works dude you and i
said that's exactly what we did we were
right in the eye line of each other at
all times that is absolutely nice that
is so true
turns out nick was in my eyesight when
ren and i were fighting it's true so i
was literally watching you guys yeah he
was standing right next to us apparently
four feet from each other like he was
sitting in a chair i was hiding behind a
sign right next to each other